three rochester new york police officers
have been removed from patrol
after video showed them pepper spraying
a nine-year-old handcuffed girl
we want to warn you the video is tough
to watch
the incident began with a parent telling
officers the girl had threatened to harm
herself and
others at one point an officer told the
girl she was acting like a child she
replied
i am a child police say they pepper
sprayed her after she refused to listen
to commands
and kicked an officer as you can imagine
the incident
has led to an outcry including a march
to a rochester police precinct by
protesters yesterday
one officer has been suspended and two
others are now on leave
the girl was taken to the hospital and
then released to her parents
you know you said the video would be
disturbing i'm not even quite sure what
i'm looking at there i just know that
you can hear the girl clearly in
distress and i i know there are two
sides every story we're always raised
that way
but i can't imagine any circumstance
that a grown-ass man
can't control a nine-year-old girl who
who is not armed i i don't understand
what happens pictures are awful i think
there's also a third side to it which is
police don't want to be in that
situation if you have mental health
workers there
then the police can take a back seat
yeah that's what we've been talking
about we talked about it a lot yeah
and now you just don't i mean it's why
are you pepper spraying a nine-year-old
girl
it's just how does it get to that
there's more to this story for sure